kaum ein anderes religiöses oberhaupt
erreicht so viele menschen weltweit und
über die religionsgrenzen hinweg wie
tenzin gyatso die oberste autorität der
tibetischen buddhisten
sein anliegen ist es die erreichung des
glücks durch vervollkommnung des geistes
für den einzelnen wie für die menschheit
wie er das erreichen will
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit seiner
heiligkeit eine sternstunde religion
ihre heiligkeit ich heiße sie herzlich
willkommen zu unserer sendung
es ist eine ehre hier bei uns zu haben
danke das ist auch mir eine ehre sie
sind ein unermüdlicher verfechter des
dialogs nicht nur des dialogs zwischen
den religionen sondern auch zwischen
politik wissenschaft und spiritualität
speciality meist auf ich arbeite als
muslimin seit 20 jahren im
interreligiösen dialog dabei kommt immer
wieder eine bestimmte frage auf was
raised frequently wenn menschen ihren
reden zuhören oder ihre bücher lesen
sind diese menschen bereiten offen für
den dialog
doch wie erreichen sie die menschen
welche nicht bereit oder nicht die alu
billig sind weil wir alle menschliche
wesen sind haben wir auch die fähigkeit
nachzudenken
sie sind wir alle haben die fähigkeit
die dinge ganzheitlich zu betrachten
nicht nur aus kurzfristigem sondern auch
aus langfristigem interesse und
neutronen schottland am inn fest
normalerweise und besonders dann wenn
sich emotionen entwickeln dann nutzen
die menschen ihre fähigkeit nicht die
realität ganzheitlich wahrzunehmen
die menschen nutzen dieses potenzial
nicht immer und dann tendieren sie zur
kurzsichtigkeit was ihnen
es scheint unmittelbar eine gewisse
befriedigung bringt indem sie die
anderen kritisieren ihnen schaden oder
im schlimmsten fall sogar töten bereitet
dass diese menschen befriedigung
das ist kurzsichtig längerfristig
gesehen ist niemand daran interessiert
ich glaube dass die menschliche natur
grundsätzlich mitfühlender ist zudem
haben wir unser wunderbares gehirn durch
erziehung durch bewusst sein können sich
diese menschen ändern
sie können lernen die dinge nicht mehr
nur unmittelbar zu betrachten sondern
weitsichtiger es ist bei jedem problem
so wenn wir es aus der nähe betrachten
scheint es unerträglich zu sein aber
wenn wir dasselbe problem aus der
distanz betrachten dann sehen wir das
ist zwar immer noch bedauerlich ist aber
es ist auf die letzten jahrzehnte zurück
schauen sind die menschen allgemein nur
für den dialog geworden
oder eher verschlossener ich habe
folgende erfahrung gemacht
ich denke das interesse am
interreligiösen dialog ist in den
letzten zehn jahren stark gewachsen
wohin ich auch gehen auch an
interreligiösen konferenzen stelle ich
das immer wieder fest
von dieser interreligiöse dialog ist
nicht nur eine oberflächliche
angelegenheit
den menschen ist es ernst was auch immer
der vorherrschende glaube ist jede große
religiösen tradition hat dieselbe
botschaft dieselbe praxis und das ist
die praxis
mit dieser praxis geht die praxis der
toleranz oder tiger vergebung einher
philosophisch betrachtet gibt es
verschiedene konzepte
doch wir müssen uns fragen was die
absicht der verschiedenen philosophien
ist
alle haben dieselbe absicht sie sind
überzeugt vom wert der liebe vom wert
des mitgefühls
bleiben wir noch ein wenig bei den
verschiedenen philosophien und praktiken
wir erleben dass der buddhismus in
europa sehr attraktiv geworden ist
es gibt sogar unternehmen welche
buddhistische weisheit und praktiken
zumindest teilweise adaptieren
wie denken sie darüber der buddhismus
gehört traditionsgemäß zum osten
die menschen sind verschieden und haben
auch verschiedene religiöse glauben die
westen herrscht vor allem die
jüdisch-christliche tradition vor
in gewissen gebieten auch der islam
es ist sicher wenn jeder bei seinem
eigenen religiösen glauben bleibt wenn
man die religion wechselt führt es
manchmal zu verwirrungen von confusion
es ist also besser die eigene religion
zu behalten
es gibt millionen von menschen die aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht
gläubig sind gehören keiner bestimmten
glaubensrichtung altenfeld aber
gleichzeitig möchten sie eine gewisse
art spiritualität erfahren
gewisse geistes übungen praktiziert
solche menschen zeigen sich dann offen
für den buddhismus oder für andere
religionen aus der indischen tradition
verglichen etwa für den sein ismus den
buddhismus und hinduismus
das ist deren gutes recht aber wichtig
dabei ist wenn sich menschen neuen
religionen zu wenden etwa dem buddhismus
hinduismus oder zynismus und welche
ihnen persönlich mehr behagen
so bedeutet das nicht dass ihre
ursprüngliche traditionelle religion
wertlos
deshalb müssen diese menschen ihren
ursprünglichen glauben respektieren
das ist sehr wichtig weil ich sie
richtig verstanden habe dann sind die
skeptisch wenn hier leute von sich
behaupten sie seien christliche
buddhisten oder buddhistische christen
möglicherweise bedeutet als christ
glaubt man an den schöpfer an jesus
christus oder an die dreifaltigkeit
aber gleichzeitig muss man als buddhist
auch den buddhistischen glauben buddha
respektieren das ist schwierig aber auf
dieser ebene kann man das vielleicht
kombinieren
es gibt menschen die finden diese
haltung würde ihnen mehr inneren frieden
bringen einverstanden aber denn wenn man
dann aber eine tiefere ebenen erreicht
dann kommt das buddhistische konzept der
lehrzeit zum tragen
dort gibt es keinen platz mehr für einen
unabhängigen absoluten schöpfer
independent absolut trete ich verstehe
warum ich glaube es ist schon über zehn
jahre her damals habe ich mit einem
guten freund einen amerikanischen
christlichen münch ein wunderbarer
mensch diskutiert wir haben oft
miteinander diskutiert über die
praktiken seiner religion wie etwa
mitleid vergebung toleranz er war sehr
interessiert und wollte etwas lernen
über die indische tradition die
einzelnen punkte der meditation
beide wollten von der anderen tradition
mehr erfahren das haben wir gemacht
haben über solche dinge diskutiert
einmal fragte er mich wieder begriff der
lehrzeit im buddhismus zu verstehen sei
ich antwortete ihm fragt mich nicht
solche sachen
die lehrzeit gehört zum geschäft des
buddhisten nicht des christmas
sie wollen dieses konzept nicht teilen
denn ein glaubenssatz des buddhismus
lautet es gibt nichts das losgelöst
existiert one or nothing independent ex
ist im buddhismus zynismus und in
anderen altindischen religionen
allgemein in der buddhistischen glaubens
gemeinschaft gibt es das konzept des
schöpfers nicht ich wollte nicht dass
mein freund sich mit dieser sichtweise
vertraut macht denn er glaubt an einen
schärfer an gott
diese sichtweise könnte eine negative
wirkung auf ihn haben
das möchte ich nicht es ist besser wenn
jeder bei seiner tradition bleibt sie in
front deshalb denken sie ist der
buddhismus für europa so attraktiv
ich denke der buddhismus allgemein
insbesondere aber der buddhismus in der
nordindischen tradition oder selbst
legte fest und rät uns dort praktizierte
meine lehre nicht einfach blind nur
durch glaube und hingabe sondern fortan
8 und mache experimente das hat oder
aufgetragen in der nordindischen
tradition der salz crypt radiation
wendet man reichlich logische
untersuchungen und experimente es gibt
leute die eher wissenschaftlich denken
und die vernunft lieben wie der
vorletzte papst den ich dem deutschen
papst zu nennen pflegen sich er sagte
glaube und vernunft müssen zusammen
gehen solche menschen welche eine
wissenschaftliche denkweise haben oder
die vernunft lieben werden gewisse ideen
nicht einfach durch glauben annehmen
ich denke dass für solche menschen die
buddhistische vorgehensweise anziehend
ist also verstand und experiment zu
gebrauchen
menschen aus dem westen die am
buddhismus interessiert sind lieben wenn
ich das so sagen darf den blinden
glauben nur die praxis ohne innere
überzeugung ohne zu denken nur glauben
das ist ungesund
das ist nicht gut
lassen sie uns zu einem weiteren thema
kommen die buddhistische islamischen
beziehungen ist der samsung gibt es
zurzeit einen buddhistisch islamischen
dialog wurde ist islamisch bei lok ist
nicht besonders rege aber in ladakh in
nordindien schon traditionsgemäß besteht
dort eine enge beziehung zwischen den
buddhisten und den muslimen schon seit
vielen jahren pflege ich enge
beziehungen zur muslimischen brüdern und
schwestern sowohl zu schiiten als auch
zu mieten
erst vor kurzem war ich in ladakh auf
einer pilgerreise am gleichen tag habe
ich zuerst die buddhistischen tempel
besucht und dann den sunnitischen tempel
die sunnitische moschee und dann die
schiitische moschee das alles am
gleichen tag am gleichen morgen
die us liebe gehören zu einer der
wichtigsten weltreligion
sie sind anhänger des islam des koran
der islam ist eine sehr wichtige
religion
viele muslime sind wunderbare menschen
es gibt auch bösartige menschen wie sie
jede religionsgemeinschaft wie sie auch
der buddhismus hat der hinduismus hat
das christentum oder das judentum oder
wer auch immer bösartiger menschen gibt
es überall
diese wenigen bösartigen menschen
repräsentieren niemals die ganze
tradition
wir müssen diese unterscheidung macht
heutzutage etwas passiert heißt es
gewöhnlich die muslime sind terroristen
oder wenn etwas in burma passiert dann
heißt es die buddhisten sind terroristen
so es ist völlig falsch
muslim den war muslime oder wahre
buddhisten fügen anderen menschen
niemals leicht zu der muslim ist nach
dem islam dem koran muss jeder der den
islam praktiziert jeder praktizierende
muslime freut die rechte der anderen
respektieren klärten brachat und in dem
moment wo er blut vergießt ist er in
wirklichkeit kein praktizierender
gläubiger muslim im eigentlichen sinne
mir einer meiner muslimischen freunde
sagte muir
wer den islam praktiziert muss liebe
verbreiten und zwar gegenüber der
gesamten schöpfung
ich bin einverstanden
dennoch möchte ich zwei ereignisse
diskutieren die die buddhistische
islamischen beziehungen mit geformt
haben dürften dass eine liegt 15 jahre
zurück als die taliban die buddha
statuen im afghanischen bamiyan tal
zerstört haben alle in afghanistan
wie hat dieser barbarische akt
symbolistisch islamischen beziehungen
beeinflusst zu jener zeit wurde ich von
einigen buddhisten aus verschiedenen
buddhistischen ländern kritisiert weil
ich zu diesem ereignis geschwiegen haben
ich denke vergangenheit ist
vergangenheit
heute ist das kein buddhistisches gebiet
mehr buddha statuen waren für die
einheimischen offenbar nicht so
bedeutend
das ist meine meinung das ist
bemerkenswert
wirft man einen blick auf die geschichte
dann hat es immer schon solche
zerstörungen und verwüstungen durch
muslime gegeben wie etwa in landau ich
denke auch dass vieles to pass durch
muslime zerstört wurden
vergangenheit ist vergangenheit immer
das gleiche zu wiederholen hat keinen
wert der vergangenheit ist vergangenheit
schreiten wir zu gegenwart die haben
eben auch puma erwähnt von der situation
im januar weiß man dass die muslimische
minderheit die rohingya verfolgt werden
der führenden politischen figur und
chefdiplomatin angst anzuziehen
die wie sie trägerin des
friedensnobelpreises ist wird
vorgeworfen dass sie zu den
vorkommnissen schweigt
was ist ihre haltung dazu ein übergriff
als die nachricht um die welt ging das
buddhistische mönche gewaltsam gegen die
muslimische minderheit vorgehen war ich
in medien leute wollten meine meinung
dazu erfahren ich war sehr traurig und
sagte jene buddhisten sollten sich mal
wo das gesicht vorstellen mit genau in
jenem moment das fest denn bei ihnen
diese negativen gefühle hochkommen
genau dann sollten sie sich bout das
gesicht vor augen führen und das psn
buddha kommen würde würde er definitiv
jene muslimischen brüder und schwestern
beschützen
das ist eine sehr traurige geschichte
danach hatte ich ein paar mal die
gelegenheit mich mit aung san suu kyi zu
treffen
bei den treffen der nobelpreisträger aus
einem mal traf ich sie kurz in london
ich habe ihr gesagt sie müsse etwas
dagegen unternehmen
daraufhin sagte sie das sei sehr
kompliziert das militär sei dafür
zuständig und es sei selber darin
verwickelt sein kann es ist ich
meinerseits habe an sie appelliert aber
sie fand es schwierig ich habe keine
beziehung und zu boden
ich war noch nie da ein überwinden was
uns hier in europa erstaunt sie ihre
heiligkeit lehnen gewalt strikte ab
mailand was wir aber da sehen ist gewalt
ausgehend von buddhistischen mönchen
das erstaunt uns weil der buddhismus das
image einer gewaltlosen religion hat das
habe ich vorher schon erwähnt buddhisten
die sich muench gewänder anziehen und
gewalt anwenden sind keine waren
polizisten
das gilt auch für muslime von denen sie
sagen diejenigen die verbrechen begehen
stehen außerhalb ja jene die gewalt
anwenden und terroristen sind es sind
keine waren buddhisten oder muslime gut
lassen sie uns auf unserer gesellschaft
hier zurückkommen
für den mann ist nicht buddhisten nur
weil man dieses gewand trägt
einmal war ich in mexiko dort wurde ich
von katholiken in eine katholische
universität eingeladen
als ich da an kam waren viele bischöfe
anwesend ich sagte ihnen manchmal
scheint es als ob er uns geistlichen
unser glaube an der kleidung so lange
wird diese kleider an haben hält man uns
für heilige menschen
wenn wir unsere kleider oder gewänder
ausziehen dann sind wir keine richtigen
gläubigen aber manche bischöfe und
andere priester bekommen solche
kommentare oft zu hören ließ religion
ist eine geistige haltung und hat nichts
zu tun mit einem körperlichen
erscheinungsbild von rebellenchef ein
buddhistin eine mönchsgewand der im
geist böse und gewalttätig ist oder gar
tötet ist kein wahrer buddhist mehr
empfinden ihre heiligkeit je wut
gelegentlich begegnet sie ihrer mut zum
beispiel meine mitarbeiter ganz kleine
fehler machen
das dauert aber du ein paar sekunden
dann ist es wieder vorbei
wir haben über die wut gesprochen und
sind schon fast am schluss aber lassen
sie uns erst noch über ein anderes
gefühl sprechen
eines das vielleicht so gut führen kann
unser gesellschaftlich zurzeit stark
bestimmt durch das gefühl von angst
besonders groß ist die angst bei uns in
europa unsere kulturelle identität zu
verlieren durch emigration und
globalisierung
wie denken sie darüber als jemand der
selbst die erfahrung von flucht und
leben im exil kennt gleichzeitig kämpft
auch ihr folgen seine kulturelle und
religiöse identität
sie bringen also beide perspektiven mit
was sagen sie menschen hier welche um
den verlust ihrer kulturellen identität
führt zurzeit kommen viele flüchtlinge
aus afrikanischen arabischen gebieten
ich schätze es dass man in europa so
viele flüchtlinge aufnimmt und ihnen
schutz und unterschlupf gewährte dem
shirt es ist wunderbar
vor allem die deutsche kanzlerin
sie zeigt wirklich menschlichkeit
gleichzeitig finde ich und das habe ich
auch schon vorher in einem anderen
zusammenhang erwähnt wenn die eu aber
tausende oder millionen von flüchtlingen
aufnimmt sollte sie ihnen auch schutz
gewährte den kindern und muss sie den
zugang zur bildung ermöglichen
in jungen menschen eine ausbildung
man sollte nicht vergessen dass diese
menschen mit der zeit in ihre heimat
zurückkehren und ihre heimat wieder
aufbauen
dann sollten die länder die die
flüchtlinge aufnehme ihnen auch nach der
rückkehr in deren heimat weiterhelfen
kann die newslettern sie nahtlos auch
dort beim wiederaufbau unterstützen mich
so wie ihnen wenn nötig auch kapital
beschaffen
dies empfand es können nicht alle
menschen aus dem arabischen raum hierher
kommen sonst sind ihre länder entvölkern
es können nur ein paar wenige kann in
den arabischen ländern gibt es ein
großes potenzial es lasst sie aufbauen
bild
sie konnten bisher nicht in ihre heimat
zurückkehren wenn ich sie nun bitte eine
vorausschau zu machen
die denken sie wie wir die welt in 50
jahren
1996 hatte ich gelegenheit die mutter
der queen zu treffen
sie war damals 96 jahre alt sie hat also
fast ein ganzes jahrhundert miterlebt
ich fragte sie was denken sie werden die
welt und die menschheit besser bleiben
sie gleich oder werden sie schlecht ohne
zu zögern antwortete sie besser sie
fügte ein beispiel an als sie jung war
sprach noch niemand über menschenrechte
oder das recht auf selbstbestimmung
heute sind solche themen allgemeingültig
letzten jahrhunderts hauptsächlich zu
beginn des letzten jahrhunderts waren
die menschen ihm vor allem die
wissenschaftler begeistert nuklearwaffen
herzustellen
im letzteren teil des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts ist immer mehr darüber
gesprochen worden wie man dieser waffen
abrüsten
in den letzten jahren hat obama sogar
davon gesprochen diese waffen zu
verbieten und die welt atomwaffenfrei zu
machen das sind positive zeichen auch
für die totalitären systeme der gedanke
ohne waffen hat zu einer veränderung der
denkweise gefahr weil die eigenen
bewohner sich geändert haben ist die
damalige sowjetunion zusammengebrochen
ist ihnen viele osteuropäische länder
sind heute freie länder china
was mehr nordkorea weniger nun auch
china hat sich schon stark verändert es
ist zwar immer noch kommunistisch und
hat dieselbe verfassen
aber die realität hat sich sehr
verändert
es ist zeichen der veränderung
verdeutlicht folgendes beispiel in china
gibt es heute etwa 400 millionen
buddhisten damals während der
kulturrevolution wurde jeder glaube
vorsätzlich zerstört dies muss hat aber
überlegt heute gibt es in china
wie vorher bereits erwähnt etwa 400
millionen buddhisten und wohl etwas
weniger als 200 millionen christen das
sind große veränderung
wie optimistisch ich glaube an die
menschheit die letzten jahre gab es
immer wieder treffen von
wissenschaftlern dass wissenschaftler
vorher untersucht haben wird nun
bestätigt
die menschen sind heute grundsätzlich
mitfühlender hessische minister ist more
compassion das ist einfach
nachzuvollziehen die ständige angst ich
lerne ständige zorn frist unser ganzes
immunsystem auf kassel immunsystem
komplett meint mehr mitgefühl mehr
frieden hilft uns unsere gesundheit zu
behalten
dew münchen gut hält wenn jemand
wirklich von wert des mitgefühls
überzeugt ist dann hilft das allen
religionen diese inneren werte aufrecht
zu erhalten
ihre heiligkeit wir sind bereits am ende
ich danke ihnen dafür dass ihr wissen
und ihre weisheit mit uns geteilt haben